Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
J'ai 38 ans.
Je m'appelle Eva Ménard.
Et il y a aujourd’hui
deux cœurs qui battent en moi.
Il m’a fallu pas mal d’années
pour en arriver là,
vouloir un enfant,
pour beaucoup de raisons.
L'une d'entre elles se cache dans une
épreuve qui a commencé à l'adolescence.
J'ai alors quatorze ans.
Quelque chose de très étrange se produit.
Je suis dans ma chambre,
en train d’écrire,
et au même moment, je me retrouve
sur un banc face à la mer.
Et au même moment,
dans la cuisine de mon enfance
où je suis une petite fille.
Des taches roses apparaissent
dans les airs,
et je me vois en dehors
de mon propre corps.
À ce moment-là, je suis incapable
de me rappeler comment je m’appelle,
ni où je suis.
Après un long moment de panique,
Je reviens à moi et je pense :
« Ma fille, tu es complètement folle,
il ne faut surtout pas que ça se sache. »
Je ne dis rien à personne
et j’implore ma tête d’avoir la décence
de ne jamais refaire « ça ».
Quatre ans plus tard, le même accident.
Puis trois ans plus tard, puis
deux, puis un,
puis tous les mois
et bientôt chaque semaine.
J'ai 24 ans.
À ce moment-là, ma vie d’artiste
est déjà bien avancée.
Je suis compositrice,
auteure et interprète.
J’ai un groupe avec mon amoureux,
avec lequel on tourne beaucoup
en France, à l’étranger.
Les petites nuits s’enchaînent,
on répète, on compose, on joue,
et une idée sournoise s’insinue
dans mon esprit.
Et si un accident m’arrivait sur scène ?
Cet été-là, je dirige une gigantesque
chorale dans un spectacle de 2 heures.
Je suis sous les feux des projecteurs
et je me demande :
« Vais-je perdre la boule,
là, maintenant, tout de suite ?
Comment vais-je diriger la centaine
de chanteurs en face de moi
si je suis là et dans ma salle de bain,
sans plus comprendre
trois notes de musique ? »
Quand un accident m’arrive,
si je me regarde dans le miroir,
je suis incapable de savoir
qui est la personne en face.
Imaginez :
votre identité vous est volée,
et par vous-même en plus.
Vos liens, vos souvenirs
avec les gens disparaissent.
Alors vous avez terriblement
honte de vous-même
et vous préférez continuer à le cacher.
Si je ne parle pas et que je m'isole
pendant la crise de panique qui suit,
personne ne peut savoir ce qui m'arrive.
Un jour, un accident m'arrive
avec mon amoureux.
Et là, il voit immédiatement
qu’il y a un problème.
Longuement, après être revenue à moi,
je me lance, je ne peux plus le cacher.
Et je commence à lui raconter,
à lui, puis à ma sœur.
Je trouve difficilement les mots
pour leur dire ce qui se passe.
Je suis là et dans un milliard
d’endroits en même temps.
Je vois, j’entends des choses
qui n’existent pas.
Comme tout ça se passe dans ma tête,
je décide d’aller consulter un psy.
Je ne pense hélas pas être tombée
sur le couteau le plus aiguisé du tiroir.
Puisque, à peine a-t-il entendu deux
minutes de mon histoire qu’il sait déjà.
Il va régler tout ça avec une bonne
grosse psychanalyse sur mon enfance.
J’ai mes casseroles, comme tout le monde.
Mais je pressens là comme un décalage
entre le remède suggéré
et le problème auquel je fais face.
J'ai 26 ans.
L’explication va venir
d’une source inattendue.
Mon dos est complètement bloqué.
Je vais voir mon ostéopathe
et à la fin de la séance,
elle manipule mon crâne.
Et là, elle remarque quelque
chose de très bizarre.
Il ne bouge plus du tout.
Elle me demande
s’il s’est passé quelque chose.
La veille, j’ai eu un de ces accidents.
Et là, je fond en larmes,
en slip sur sa table.
Je pleure toutes ces années
à le cacher le plus fort possible
et à me convaincre que ce n'est rien.
Elle recueille simplement
et avec bienveillance ma peine
et elle me glisse
le numéro d’un neurologue.
Je suis épileptique.
Il m’a fallu plus de dix ans
pour découvrir le diagnostic.
Une errance en grande partie
liée à mon silence.
C’est une des leçons d’ailleurs
qui me restent de cette période.
Peu importe l’obstacle que vous traversez,
ne restez pas seul avec.
Il y a tellement de gens qui vivent
la même chose que vous,
qui peuvent vous aider
et que vous pourrez aider.
L’épilepsie, c’est un dérèglement
de l’activité électrique du cerveau,
comme un orage qui court circuite
votre intérieur.
Ça peut mettre un peu de temps avant
que le courant ne revienne correctement.
Moi, l’image que j’en avais
avant d’être concernée,
c’est l’enfant qui s’effondre dans
une salle de classe et qui convulse.
Mais j'ai découvert que cette maladie
revêt des formes incroyablement variées.
Chez moi, ce sont majoritairement
des crises partielles.
Des tas de zones s'allument dans
mon cerveau, mais pas toutes.
C'est pour ça que je suis
encore consciente.
Je peux être dans le passé, dans un
espace-temps qui ne fait aucun sens
et être encore avec vous.
Dans ma tête, si vous voulez, c’est un peu
comme un sapin de Noël qui s’allume,
mais moins version joyeuses fêtes
que film d’horreur.
Quand je reçois le diagnostic,
je suis soulagée.
Je ne suis pas folle.
Je me souviens avoir cru
que c’était une ligne d’arrivée.
Hasard de la vie, alors qu’on cherche
un label avec notre groupe de musique -
un label indépendant -
une très grosse maison de disques
nous propose de nous signer chez elle.
Le diagnostic, la signature,
deux étapes qui ressemblent beaucoup
au franchissement d’un cap.
J’ai dit « ressemble » seulement,
pourquoi ?
Avec l’arrivée du diagnostic,
je vais découvrir
un merveilleux champ d’interdits :
arrêter de travailler la nuit,
le stress, les voyages qui fatiguent,
donc les tournées, arrêter de conduire,
ne pas faire de boxe, etc.
Ça tombe bien, j'adore la belote
en solo à la maison.
Je commence un traitement médicamenteux
qui remplit ses promesses à 200%...
sur les effets secondaires,
mais zéro sur la fréquence des crises.
Je deviens apathique,
dors modestement 14 h par nuit,
Fais une ou deux siestes par jour,
une ou deux crises par jour,
et j’ai la vivacité d’esprit d’une dinde
amputée d’un seul de ses deux neurones.
La seule partie sympathique du traitement,
c’est ma désinhibition nouvelle
qui mène à de cocasses échanges
avec de sombres inconnus.
Une fois, on veut jouer dans un des plus
gros festivals de découverte d’Europe.
À un concert par hasard,
je vois le directeur au loin,
que je n’avais jamais vu auparavant.
Je lui fonce dessus,
je lui claque la bise,
et je lui fais une blague incroyablement
pourrie sur son nom de famille.
Ben, on n’a pas été programmés.
Comme les médocs ne tiennent pas
leurs promesses,
notre parcours en maisons
de disques est intéressant,
mais nous contraint à une stratégie
dans le processus de création
qui ne nous ressemble pas.
Pondre absolument des singles
pour passer en radio
alors qu’on fait de la musique
indie depuis nos débuts
nous fait l’effet de vouloir
faire entrer un rond turbulent
dans un tout petit carré.
Je fais des crises presque tous les jours.
Je suis pharmaco-résistante.
Le protocole ne fonctionne pas.
Je ne sais pas vivre autrement
qu’en enchaînant les nuits blanches,
l’intensité émotionnelle
ou le stress des premières.
Avec les crises, ma mémoire ressemble
plus à celle de Tata Germaine
qu’à une jeune femme
dans la force de l’âge.
Des souvenirs qui ne me disent rien, alors
que la photo atteste que je suis présente.
J’en suis déjà là.
J’ai 27 ans
et je me pose alors quatre questions.
Un :
est-il réaliste de penser que
je peux poursuivre ma carrière
avec des crises quasi journalières ?
Deux : jusqu’où ma mémoire
va-t-elle continuer à décliner ?
Trois : vais-je devenir une charge
pour mon entourage ?
Et quatre :
dans ces conditions, comment
pourrais-je un jour seulement imaginer
vouloir fonder une famille ?
Je me souviens d'un moment précis.
Je suis en train de conduire.
Je n’avais pas le droit, mais mon assureur
n’en saura jamais rien, n’est-ce pas ?
Je m’arrête au bord d’un champ,
je descends, m’assois sur l’herbe.
Je pense être quelqu’un d’assez joyeux,
mais pour la première
et unique fois de ma vie, je pense,
je n’ai plus envie de vivre.
Pas comme ça.
Et c’est là que tout a changé.
Parce que, oui, je veux vivre
Alors, dans le creux de la vague,
je commence à m’approprier cette maladie,
à comprendre que personne ne fait
les mêmes crises pour les mêmes raisons.
Personne ne réagit pareil au traitement.
Je parle à mon neurologue,
décide d’arrêter les médicaments
et je commence à me pencher
sur des solutions alternatives
pour essayer de réduire les crises.
J'essaye de comprendre empiriquement
ce qui les déclenche.
Et comme pour beaucoup
de personnes épileptiques,
assez vite, le manque de sommeil
devient une évidence.
Après une décennie à travailler
jusqu’à 5 h du matin,
j’entrevois là un petit challenge.
Mais je réalise, qu’entre
ma couleur de cheveux et les crises,
il y a quelques centaines d’années,
j’aurais été bonne pour le bûcher.
Alors je relativise.
Et je commence par le sport.
Je me mets à courir en forêt
et l’amélioration de mes nuits
est assez vite impressionnante.
J’ajoute alors d’autres sports,
beaucoup de sports :
natation, fitness, yoga,
Pilates, rando, cardio, badminton.
Je me force à travailler
plus le jour et moins la nuit.
Et j’atteins une crise tous les deux mois.
Je comprends qu’il faut
se libérer de la voix des autres
pour pouvoir penser et agir librement,
et la même chose se passe
dans notre sphère professionnelle.
On fait une contre-proposition
à notre maison de disques,
ce qui ne se fait pas trop à l'époque.
On récupère le budget
destiné à être dépensé
dans un gros studio branché de la capitale
pour créer notre propre studio
d’enregistrement et enregistrer l’album,
et ainsi s’autonomiser pour les années
à venir avec notre outil de travail.
Un nouveau réflexe naît dans mon esprit :
celui de s’autoriser à créer un chemin
que l’on n’a jamais vu.
Je commence aussi l’autohypnose
pour pouvoir conditionner
positivement mes nuits.
Puis la méditation.
Et je découvre le champ
du développement personnel.
Je me dis que les problèmes de
mémoire d’une personne âgée
peuvent ne pas être une fatalité.
Et je trouve des exercices
pour l’entraîner,
exactement comme avec le sport.
Je me lave les dents avec la main gauche,
me conditionne pour retenir les prénoms
et je trouve des compléments alimentaires
pour favoriser la régénération neuronale.
Et devinez quoi ?
Ça marche.
Je réalise alors que tous ces ingrédients
stabilisent non seulement mon épilepsie,
mais ils changent, ils bouleversent
profondément ma vie.
Il améliore profondément
l’image de moi, ma conscience,
ma qualité de travail
et de relation aux autres.
C’est comme si l’épilepsie
m’avait appris à mieux vivre finalement.
La question est :
« L’aurais-je fait sans elle ? »
En parallèle, on quitte définitivement
notre maison de disques
pour fonder
notre propre maison d’artistes,
un collectif dont l’objectif
est la création transdisciplinaire.
On abat les barrières entre cinéma,
musique, théâtre, arts visuels et autres,
et on se rassemble entre artistes
et personnes et acteurs,
dans cet état d’esprit
de partage de savoir-faire,
connaissances et outils de travail.
J'ai 33 ans.
Et je m’apprête à fêter
mes un an sans crise.
(Applaudissements)
Arrêtez, vous allez me faire pleurer.
Un an sans crise
depuis plus de quinze ans.
J'enchaîne quelques nuits blanches
pour une nouvelle création.
Je fais une crise, très grosse.
Et là, je suis déçue de moi-même.
En voyant ma réaction, je comprends qu’il
me reste une dernière étape à franchir :
accepter ma maladie, pleinement.
C’est le moment pour moi d’en parler,
pas seulement à mes proches,
de prendre une parole publique
sur le sujet en tant qu’artiste
afin de transcender ma blessure.
Je compose un morceau
qui s’appelle « Orage »
et qui raconte ce qui se passe
dans ma tête durant une crise.
J’explique ce qui est le plus
difficile pour moi :
perdre le lien avec les gens que j'aime.
J’écris et je coréalise
le clip qui l’accompagne
et décide de les sortir le 8 février 2021
à l’occasion de la
Journée internationale de l’épilepsie.
Voilà, tout est dit.
Jamais je n'aurais pu imaginer
les conséquences.
J’ai reçu des centaines de messages,
de plein de pays,
de personnes épileptiques
ou d’autres qui vont
découvrir le diagnostic
en se reconnaissant
dans les symptômes dont je parle,
de familles désemparées
ou des gens qui, comme moi auparavant,
ont honte d’eux-mêmes et se cachent.
L’Association Épilepsie France
me demande de devenir leur marraine
pour mon plus grand honneur.
Je découvre des gens qui dédient leur vie
à l’amélioration de mes semblables
d’une façon incroyable.
Je me retrouve à en parler publiquement
et à écrire la postface
d’un ouvrage sur le sujet.
Le clip remporte des prix dans
les festivals de films internationaux.
Cette envie de transmettre,
elle se déploie bien sûr
dans mon monde artistique.
Avec le collectif,
on intègre de jeunes artistes
avec qui l’on partage nos outils
de développement de carrière
et cette conscience du pouvoir
de la collaboration.
On fait également grandir nos ambitions
avec une activité
cinématographique croissante.
Je m’empare pleinement du métier
de scénariste et de réalisatrice.
Comme un symbole,
Après avoir raconté
mon histoire en musique,
raconter des histoires en images vient
s’ajouter au bâtiment de ma création.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai 38 ans.
L’Eva de 38 ans a envie de dire
à l’ado terrifiée de quatorze piges :
« N’aie pas honte de toi.
Cette épreuve,
c’est une aventure
qui va te faire grandir,
te nourrir humainement et artistiquement.
Elle va te donner
un équilibre fantastique. »
Depuis lors, bien sûr, la vie a jeté
d’autres embûches sur ma route.
Mais l’épilepsie m’a offert de m’apprendre
énormément de choses dont ceci :
accepte ce que tu ne peux changer,
lâcher prise où tu ne peux rien,
et agis sur ce sur quoi tu peux agir,
trouve un chemin,
peu importe le projet,
trouve un chemin personnel unique.
Extravagance du hasard,
le jour où l’on m’a proposé
de parler devant vous,
c’est le jour où j’ai appris
que j’étais enceinte.
Comme une touchante coïncidence
en direction de la transmission.
Comme un appel à vous raconter ce chemin
et à en embrasser un nouveau.
Je sais déjà que lorsque je serai mère,
s’il m’arrive une crise,
je ne serai pas capable
de reconnaître mon propre enfant.
Mais je n'ai plus peur de ça.
L’orage peut venir, oui ;
maintenant, je le sais.
Toujours, l’orage va passer.
(Applaudissements)
(Vidéo : « Orage »)
(Musique)
Encore une fois dans un soupir
L’orage gagne tous mes souvenirs
Je voudrais tant te retenir
La nuit s’étire sur moi
Ramène-moi, si je...
Ramène-moi, quand je...
Ramène-moi
Quand je quitte le temps
Ramène-moi, si je...
Ramène-moi, quand je...
Ramène-moi
Quand je glisse
Si...
Si je m’échappe
Sauve...
Sauve-moi
Si...
Si je m’évade
Sauve...
Sauve-moi
Tic tac expire sans revenir
Mes yeux dérivent, l’enfer devient désir
Je m’obstine à ne pas partir
Je veux si fort me souvenir
De ce que tu es pour moi
Ce que je suis pour toi
Comment tu ris pour moi
Comment je vis
Ce que tu es pour moi
Ce que je suis pour toi
Comment je ris
Pour toi ici
Si...
Si je m’échappe
Sauve...
Sauve-moi
Si...
Si je m’évade
Sauve...
Sauve-moi
Si...
Si je m’échappe
Sauve...
Sauve-moi
Si...
Si je m’évade
Sauve...
Sauve-moi
(Fin de la musique)